the only thing that goes better with
punches than another punch is a punch
line
there are two schools of thought with
superhero movies funny movies serious
movies yeah
funny funny it's if I gonna be bad cuz I
say serious I don't think that serious
means saans fun songs humor
just like when it's a little bit more
real every time that you speak French
that makes me understand that you like
serious superhero yes I got it going
back to the things like Adam West you
can't be Batman that's a little bit too
far in that direction for my you are so
good at that
no with the comedy it can sometimes hide
but I would assume to be kind of maybe a
weaker plot sometimes shots fired I know
not all of them I think there's a way to
do both there is a way to do it seems
like DC movies just skew so far to the
serious side and then when there are
gags and it's like that's kind of weird
cuz doesn't fit like the rest of the
tone that you've built why so serious
and the answer is Oscar nominated Logan
and I just always go back to that one to
me it's the pinnacle of what you can do
Thor I think they really found the right
recipe with it when they went comedic I
gotta tell you how much better store got
because he started out as like Kurt
Cobain with a hammer to me and I was
like not impressed the only thing that
goes better with punches than another
punch it's a punch lying in slow motion
so how do y'all feel about our rated
movies vs. PG whatever's did you see my
eyes light up yeah yeah yeah all the way
like Christmas I want my super Hill's
raw a little bit nasty
I want violence I want all those things
Deadpool they really were able to mix
this perfect recipe of comedy sex drug
violence and that was the first time
we'd really kind of seen that and it's
also what's really true to the character
yeah because that was the comic book and
everybody was so nervous going into it
that maybe they weren't gonna make it
r-rated you got to do it right yeah you
know in Deadpool is a character that
lends itself to the r-rated elements and
then someone like spider-man it doesn't
have to be that you know anybody's gotta
be weird yeah he I don't think he knows
many r-rated words hello there welcome
back I'm glad you could join me today
the other thing that Deadpool totally
nails is breaking the fourth wall it
makes everything so fun yeah it's almost
like the audience is like a secondary
character cuz we're involved in the
plotting and all of the jokes when Ryan
Reynolds does something you're like I'm
sorry me what would you look at that it
seems think we have ourselves a finished
painting prior to this most fourth wall
breaks are like maybe the occasional
Ferris Bueller but I mean this one was
everything yeah to the point where I've
started thinking about how every movie
would probably benefit from some
Deadpool commentary like the greatest
showmen
so I made a little cartoon a careful
balancing act is the secret to any lie
cuz we don't anything about PT Barnum he
was not the nicest man I am really
concerned for that elephant safety
that's fine Deadpool commentating on
other movies would make me see a bunch
of movies otherwise that I wouldn't I
don't know The Cider House Rules if you
don't like that then the piano Oh Harvey
Keitel Deadpool yeah it's me like you
miss me read I don't know what you guys
think but Deadpool feels like a romance
to me first one was like very romantic
the whole Vanessa you know trying to get
my girl back yes Nate that was his whole
objective and I was so in love with
Morena Baccarin yes she was strong but
also I'm cool that she's the damsel as
well yeah I don't think that it like to
have a good movie you need to have a
love interest and I think something like
Wonder Woman was a little hamstrung by
that because Chris Pine was great but
then it felt like she couldn't exist
unless she like fell in love with
somebody I mean I also had trouble with
the montage where ladies be shopping
I appreciate at the end of the day that
Chris Pine was there because he was
super funny and I'm the other way around
I ship everything like I ship the cast
of Riverdale if there's a new Marvel TV
show called cloak and dagger already I'm
just like get together get together so I
want everyone to fall in love both on
screen and off but how amazing would
have been if Wonder Woman like
friendzone to Chris Pine so juicy a lot
smarter than I look we talked about this
being a romance I don't know if that
first romance is gonna make it through
the second movie now the dominoes shona
domino I'm lucky I'm really excited for
the possibility of zazzy beats and
Morena Baccarin fighting each other or
loving each other there's a possibility
I always love it when love triangles get
crazy with superhero movies cuz it makes
me feel understood cuz it's just my life
like when Cyclops was with Jean Grey for
a while yeah he's with Emma Frost and
then Wolverine was like Jean Grey
Wolverine Cyclops nothing goes better
with a love triangle than lots of
spandex that we're gonna form a super
duper group it's time to get back on
LinkedIn Deadpool is the king of Easter
eggs you can watch the trailer and pick
out a million tiny little details what
do you think is gonna happen well I know
one thing exports
we got a look at Terry Crews and all of
his glory Terry Crews is bedlam y'all
and he is going to bring the electricity
my name is cable here for the kid mover
guy I cannot wait for the bad guy in
Deadpool 2 which is cable played by Josh
Brolin Brolin has really transformed
himself he really like put in the work
to get like really physically in shape
for cable I remember at d23 last year
they lined the entire cast of The
Avengers up which he's also in as they a
knows I was like look at the guns on
that show what in the ass
cables whole thing is time travel so do
you think that Deadpool is gonna go to
another time they have to yes even if
it's just a glimpse I do love dinosaurs
and I think if that pool went to the
Land Before Time that would be amazing
maybe Littlefoot comes out I'm sure
Deadpool would hate is like pure
optimism and then a little doctor you
knock I'm saying life finds a way if
Jeff Goldblum and Deadpool ever met up
there would be a rip in the space-time
continuum but life will find a way so
we're gonna play some movie trivia and
the world of this is gonna be funny
superhero movies like Thor Ragnarok
versus serious ones like Logan let's go
when did Deadpool makes economic next
who was originally cast to play
Wolverine I remember this I do too but I
know that because what is Wolverines
real name hmm
if his name is willow gondry everything
I know is wrong
well Lisa's name not brillo no criticism
excellent oh it is all right question is
shut up crime with the tagline which
superhero I really like this nod to
Blankman which superhero first debuted
in DC's tales of the unexpected hmm
I'm just really excited for Adam warlock
to make an appearance they're all Marvel
they stole Thor from DC making it truly
unexpected yeah
next question Donald Blake is the secret
identity of which superhero isn't a
magician oh it's David Blaine walks with
a cane there's a king named Donald two
times you know nice cool so we have to
tried a bunch about superhero movies
funny versus serious exhausted it yep
but tell us what you guys think about it
in the comments below and we'll read
them yes and make sure that you go to
fandango.com
and on the mobile app to get tickets to
Deadpool - I'm some chimichangas
you